well it's still the dream the dream is
of a United States of Africa and I think
it's a good dream because that again is
about building a sense of of African
identity but at the moment it's at the
regional stage and so you think yes if
they all the different regional
groupings based on the economic trading
partnerships but they're you that when
you look at them closely
yeah the dreams there but of course it
means we lose our taxes on this and we
don't you know they they could then
destroy our industry on that and it's it
gets very very very messy and they're
not moving ahead as fast as they should
because once you had a yeast African
community or West African community that
was that was real I think investors
would come in because the markets would
be that much bigger but knowing the
difficulties you have crossing borders
in Africa at the moment I don't think
they you know that that investors will
come in the sort of numbers they should
give them the wealth of the place and
the number of people